salut juste et bien l'air de très bonne
humeur aujourd'hui quasi voire je suis
en pleine forme mais les rayons et ce
matin en me regardant dans la glace je
me suis trouvée très mignon et bien tant
mieux c'est parfait comme ça on n'aura
pas besoin de te faire de compliments
oui j'ai rencontré plein de millions
venant à bout qui tu rencontres un j'ai
rencontré par la ville au maire il m'a
sifflé un nouvelle ère de sa composition
c'était très beau mais tu as raison
barnabé c'est un grand artiste au qui
attire en contre j'ai aussi rencontré
albert l'escargot par des hommes
expéditions alors je lui ai fait
traverser la route ça lui a fait gagner
au moins une demi journée sur son trajet
peut-être la chance d'avoir tous ses
amis c'est bien vrai bon je vais jouer
au ballon
d'accord padam padam padam mais c'est
monsieur du snob avec un fusil mais il
va peut-être aller tuer tous mes amis
au fond c'est affreux
mais le facteur aussi méchant aux
horribles il faut faire quelque chose je
vais je vais je valais prévenu françois
françois mais qu'est ce qui lie à casino
mais moi aussi mais tu es fou mais
pourquoi suis je fou casimir qu'est ce
qui t'arrive encore mais tu ne sais pas
que dans l'île aux enfants tous les
animaux vivent heureux en vidéo bien sûr
que je le sais casimir et chacun ici
peut être assuré de vivre heureux sans
risquer le moindre danger
et entre nous je vois vraiment pas
pourquoi tu viens de dire ça mais parce
que tu admires le recteur l'avant chers
amis vous êtes prêts pour le concours
des chasseurs délit bien vous le voyez
tout à fait prêt monsieur disney vous
devriez avoir honte tuait des pauvres
petites bêtes sans défense je ferai tout
pour les protéger ge coppet casimir
voilà l'explication de ton discours de
tout à l'heure encore une fois mon bon
casimir tout n'a rien compris
enfin tu nous connais pourtant assez
pour savoir que nous nous sont joués à
tuer l'animal dont le plaisir des
châssis mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce
concours du chasseur d'élite attend coco
qui ne fait de mal à personne
nous tirons tout simplement sur des
vieilles boîtes de conserves remplies de
morceaux de verre qui ont été cachés
dans les arbres de lille et le vainqueur
est celui qui ont trouvé qu'un à bas le
plus grand nombre à casimir des amis
animaux ne risque absolument rien ou
mais c'est l'heure les amis alors oui le
concours a commencé
casimir à tout à l'heure on est d'accord
avec à l'heure
ça me rassure bon ben j'ai une idée les
enfants venaient 1
vous allez voir le plus grand lanceur de
ballons du monde
fac daniel vien daniel portuaire à bon
goal un tu te mets là et tu arrêtes meba
que j'aurais te lancer à la main pétrin
c'est très bon alors attention
1 2 3 mais qu'est ce qui s'passe casimir
tu as cassé quelque chose non c'est rien
c'est seulement une vieille boîte qui
est fait dans un arbre ah bon ben j'ai
eu peur je prends le ballon
alors cette fois ci je marque en lui
5 à 10 me fais attention tu me fait
sursauter à chaque fois bien cette fois
là ça y est de quoi le ballon tim est
toujours pas marqué de lui aucun pas
insolent j'ai envoyé dix fois le ballon
dans les bus et chaque fois il est passé
trop il est parti dans les arbres c'est
sûrement des ballons cook et oui et puis
j'ai peur que tu t'attendais ennuis avec
monsieur du snob le facteur et sont soit
les emmener avec eux pourquoi parce que
les boîtes de conserve que tu as fait
tomber c'est celle qu'ils avaient
accroché dans les arbres pour leur
concours de tir
oh là là mais rares ils vont être
furieux et ils vont où là il faut que je
me sauve avant que j'arrive chez disnat
baril déroule à la a enfin non non non
je n'ai pas fait exprès je vous demande
pardon c'est à cause du ballon excusez
moi je ne toucherais plus jamais un
ballon mais ne me battais pas et il ne
me tirait pas dessus non enfin casimir
personne ici ne songe à 4 elle te dirais
tu si nous sommes tellement déçus de ne
pas avoir trouvé de boîtes de conserve
robin le superbe cadeau qui récompense
le vainqueur car le règlement est formel
les boîtes de conserves doit être abattu
par n'importe quel projectile est le
premier du concours
le chasseur d'élite de l'île aux enfants
c'est le tour à moi et oui casimir tu
aies gagné bravo ça sert membres avocat
zibi je me permets de te féliciter
c'était très bien
je suis très ému et maintenant julie va
te remettre ton prix art qu'est ce que
ça a surpris un superbe ballon
oh non pas un ballon
[Musique]